my biggest concern it's the time and
money mostly time because I'm gonna have
to spend times get all the ingredients
to make it zero waste and money I don't
know how much these things cost maybe
they're too expensive and I'm just
trying to make comfort mac and cheese so
I could watch Grey's Anatomy in my
nightgown
z Rosie Rosie zero I'm gonna try to make
mac and cheese with zero - we're gonna
be sustainable yes is this sustainable e
get my greetings from Trader Joe's and
rouse and I can promise they all come in
plastic so this is what I would normally
back and I added it up and it's 3583
okay that's not too crazy for them
either fancy cheese's I got ya so we'll
see how our zero waste version stacks up
in terms of price yeah let's go do the
zero waste shop away
so let's start in the bowl tile yeah
there's a bowl boy
yeah maybe pasta we need salts we need
cheese we need milk and bread crumb so
we need bread there's salt they saw okay
yes
sea salt do you want the Himalayan salt
for the sea salt
I'll get boobie on you yeah show this
from my mom she's probably gonna say I'm
fully a California girl there's the tare
weight of the bag so then you don't get
charged for the cost of the way to the
back should we get some candy yeah
which candy do you want good skip the
mothballs sounds good that doesn't
sounds like we're gonna go to the movies
yeah let's go to the movies I have seen
pasta in bulk at some places but it's
like very specialized stores so I think
we're just gonna have to see what we can
get that has the least plastic I think
do you like shells for your back enjoy
your show we can recycle the paper and
then we can trash the plastic okay so
the next item we made is mouth
okay here we got some milk and a glass
container
so this is great because when you're
done with it you can take it back and
they give you a dollar back for the
bottle oh yeah so it's like anyway use
it 200
so next up is the bridge I'm so stoked
that we found some bread package free
you know how rare that is so we need
butter you can't get better service we'd
have to like get the cream and like
churn it ourselves to make the butter
which we're not sure butter what we can
do though is to choose butter
less packaging
salted butter that I already have the
Himalayan salt which is a very strong
salt just like me you survived your
first Airways for jumping it can be a
little hectic sometimes because you're
like trying to get the wave rhythm oh
yeah the weight of the bag deducted and
everything and like so I always get a
little stressed
every time I beg chocolate at the store
I immediately want to eat it
[Music]
it's largemont wine and cheese can I
bring my own container
yeah I'm still a baby thank you
so I'm gonna to get some wine and cheese
like Parisian princesses here's our
cheese start oh wait wait
oh yes photo lovers Oh put the booty in
the air oh here's some cheese's look it
over here it is it okay if you put our
cheese in this oh we get to sample oh
yes now that's a Buddha baby it's Pizza
Pizza
we hung me much days thank you I think
it C I would beep love affair with oh
this is good cheese dance yeah that's my
new favorite shop ok yeah just cut it
just cut it oh yeah oh yeah yeah it's
just like my child's like I was in the
waiting room look she's getting weighed
oh how many ounces right now as a kid my
mom worked a lot so me and my sisters we
take nights for cooking dinner for
everyone and my fable is always mac and
cheese and I'm not saying I perfected
the mac and cheese but God dang it I'm
very close it's a mixture of two great
recipes and what makes it great is the
two women that influenced me the first
one is my mother she makes the
traditional haitian mac and cheese where
the crust as hard as hell but the middle
is gooey delicious and also i had a bus
driver in middle school when i was
getting bullied and she became one of my
closest friends and she gave me her
recipes welcome to my kitchen we're
gonna make you mac and cheese
alright it's gonna be my sous chef I'm
not a tasty chef every time I do is
kicking videos who doesn't roast me I'm
a regular regular 23 year old who
literally just survives and makes dishes
for her hoes in the dinner party waiting
for it to boil so that I could put my
word that I can't pronounce gosh shoes
I'm not Italian
can Italian maybe we'll just all Italian
in arts the first thing I need you to do
Ari I'm gonna get you a cooking board
can you please cut these into two halves
the next thing we're gonna do is make
the cheese sauce I'm gonna open in this
boozy mouth can I help you cut the
cheese
yes always put butter if you think it's
not enough butter it's not a lot better
there's no measurements this is not
tasty you just feel how much better
you'll need okay this is boiling just
want to drop that pasta and we're gonna
get the Buddha out Oh
let's make a little waste jar the first
waste is the wax from the cheese do you
want the skin of the brie can you get
this vinegar right you can you drop it
it how many slices of provolone looks
like one the months that I love I'm just
gonna let this melt and get nice and
thick so then we have a dance party to
the sounds of the pasta nice yes what
about that bread is it burnt oh oh we're
good
that looks nice and crispy no no it
looks perfect so I'm double stirring Oh
low nasty that's what they call me look
at all that crumbing going on yeah
that's a lumpy we like it won't be that
laughs I love it mixing it up just to
let the cheese's place oh you're gonna
layer more cheese mmm I knew that
then we baker it's where does paper
telescope from oh I just did you just
use them we got to put in our waste pile
okay that's just very human error it's a
learning process on this show it's a
journey to zero waste is ready
Oh looks good she ready baby we make two
batches with all the ingredients
yeah me too let's set the table young
lady - you ready try this I am how do
you think it looks so good
is there always pasta
you can tell that there are real
cheese's and it's an awesome box cheese
mix does this taste like your usual mac
and cheese notice way better really oh
my god
like how much butter mmm I'm not so
surprised my next cookout with this mac
and cheese honey so when we added up
everything in the store that you would
normally buy it was thirty five dollars
and eighty three cents but her zero
waste version was thirty five dollars
and sixty eight cents Wow so fifteen
cents cheaper I love that so zero waste
wins on money this time but we lost on
time yeah because we had to go to two
different places the trash we made was
some cheese wax this pasta container
which is actually lined with plastic so
it has to go to landfill because it's a
mixed material some paper towels we
accidentally used and then also the
butter container which we're still using
the butter but then once that's over a
week this is actually really surprising
I would have made way more mess my other
way would you make mac and cheese in
this way again like do you think in your
lifestyle you'd have time to like go to
two different places and all that
definitely really I think finding local
businesses and supporting local
businesses cut away from me the only
converting needs going to cheese shops
thank you so much for watching
tell me what you think in the comments
next week I'm gonna make my skincare
routine
zero ace emotion to play I already near
the player just because you want to save
the earth don't mean you don't want to
stop your hose what is stopping the hose
in town I don't know but you're doing
[Music]